monk your books are good but they're not
popular editors they want a black book
they have a black book I'm black and
it's my book you know what I mean I tend
to sort of lean into the discomfort with
art so I had been looking for something
to direct about the racial politics of
being a black artist in the world I just
want to rub their noses in
it and tow the line between satire and
fars I be standing outside in the night
then be dead ads rappers crack you said
you wanted black stuff that's black
right I see what you're doing it's a
pretty rare film that's stealing with
some super relevant age-old themes along
with a deep thread of comedy and irony
running through it is this based on your
actual
life yeah you think some ass
college boy can come up with that
no no no I don't thought it was really
funny and it create such a riveting
conversation
cord has a real point of
view which I think is the key to being a
great
director for it to be his first film
he's done an excellent job creating this
story that's brilliant and hysterical
that's like Dude you sure you never done
this before he's kind he's smart
goodlooking and he can write and direct
I mean who could ask for anything more
people want to love you mon you should
let them love all of you to be on a set
with all of these people around who I
grew up admiring and have them trust me
and support me in this process I'm
forever grateful for that if somebody
can walk away and say that this caused
me to think about my own life and my own
politics and also have a good time I
will be pleased at the end of the day
they're offering $4 million for moving
rights yes the Dumber I behave the
Richer I
get
we're thinking we can get it out in time
for Jun
[Music]
te